Oh everybody my name is markiplier I'm
here with yamimash hello everyone we are
left again well I guess Wade's not
joining us anymore for their seventh 7/7
having some technical difficulties and
okay okay wait Bob get get in the ocean
we got a well we're role-playing now
whoa what we're sirens we're roaming our
beautiful work oh god
wait why you gotta be crew okay we just
crashed it a plane get in cans are you
okay wait okay siren marshal survived
care so much about you Wade I knew her
ha bob is drowning ha ha ha
give him mouth-to-mouth yeah don't don't
fire her that's all on you
ok so booth Lulu we just survived that
horrible plane crash oh no my whole
family was on that plane
well where are your family now I'm not
permitted to use Apple I don't have
permissions on this island
no you're just not permitted to use
Apple like everyone else in the world
I'm amazed at I'll hungry we all are
ready to use what sword huh ha ha ha we
have no permissions aah
this is Ashley make this really
challenging straddling island by Andy I
don't understand well some mysterious
force is preventing me from putting this
Apple up to my mouth and idiot I managed
to do it somehow ok so oh oh sixteen or
whatever it's all I got kicked again by
likely is my good okay we got a jaw me
turn up your microphone volume here a
little low okay I mean shout louder cuz
we're not oh yeah oh yeah maker what a
cuz I didn't screw that up already
nevermind alright
as a self-proclaimed leader of our group
finally bash hello hi hi we mosh
hardening Melina no wait the leader I've
got a magical conch and it says that
Yami is the leader and there's something
over here there's a switch
oh good why do I feel like it blows this
up hey everyone gather around real close
all right we're ready
hi oh I heard that see ya oh oh was it
in the opening scene of lost yeah
the our first episode right this then
didn't suck someone in and blow up
didn't it I told you guys this was lost
oh I'm gonna I'm gonna be the old guy in
the wheelchair okay I never watched that
show me neither
I always think some of the first episode
but we're gonna break it up the black
spoke it's ok Bob we know enough to get
by so marks the black smoke I'll be jack
I'm the black smoke what can I be the
fat guy who everyone likes yeah Hugh
yeah anyway don'tdon't Don we got a
survive in the woods here
Who am I don't trust you I already
proclaimed you to be the evil character
from the show okay Rick what are you say
no no character from Walking Dead washed
up on ya care shoot Walking Dead on lost
grade while walking lost first position
set I'm setting positions are not
chopping down trees what's going on I've
come to dead lost they're even lost more
lost than before Oh clever best episode
crossovers ever walking lost alright
shut up wait how stupid you're stupid
shame you know I said the walking loss
like 32 seconds to berries was good Bob
but here okay I was busy trying to read
why I can't chop down trees yeah does it
say
wait it's because God hates you my my
wooden axe automatically transformed
into stone and all of a sudden it works
this island is so magical shut up
alright so anyway what are we doing are
we at lits
I'm I'm gathering wood we should build a
Haho screw ahead it's impossible we ship
out a boat oh you know a boathouse
let's build a boathouse
like it strong all right
a restaurant why restaurant I have a I
have a boat let's start with my boat
we're gonna take your boat with that
I'll put that on the water and then you
guys could start building a house around
you're gonna make it entirely out of
source of iron near here we're not gonna
be that man if only there was a big pile
of iron somewhere what are we ever going
to do for our iron ah ah thank you my
rehearsal I'm waiting for that all right
guys the boat the boat is in boat is a
non-stop beginning to house oh I'm in
the ocean that's the boat word holonomy
a spider spider demon spider ah I appear
to be unable to control the vote in any
way I just see your arms flailing
seriously not controlling this bow
what's happening here keep moving your
arms it's like doing doing doing doing
doing you stupid it's just moving around
on a control oblique a boat - no I have
a boat I have a boat why do I have a
boat huh mommy in the house it's moving
in right of directions yeah see you
thought I was full I'm saying you crash
if you crash your yeah paralia cross
your boat it'll like if I Ram into this
dock here boom stuck
oh is this who is this building is that
yeah me okay you do not understand the
point of the show
don't ever sir question is there so poi
ah all right I got another boat ha I'm
just gonna launch a fleet of boats here
you all can enjoy your leisure
this is going to be the angel at the
front is a test the angel what her
mermaid revver they put on the front of
boon Oh
Oh Martin away from my building I have a
fleet of Nate Ivan nasal is my Navy you
know my rehearsal does not approve of
you Bob punched me I'm not moving I'm
the gods above don't approve everything
in this game so paint wait he
disappeared again
it's first-rate uncle suckers but by
forever boy there was some kind of logic
behind him get him get him
i buy civilizations and I got Charlie
wish I had some sort of gun ramming
speed han da dun dun dun dun dun dun dun
dun dun dun
boom oh I thought the I thought our
boats are gonna pop damn it that's
stupid those two I'm going home screw
you y'all but you go out there I'm just
gonna keep going nestling good yeah okay
ah tickets me forgotten already boom
boom hey my boat didn't pop there goes
okay
oh we actually like you're like your
design wet oh yeah thank you you're
actually building a boat yeah I thought
we never nobody said oh we're actually
doing what we say what me I know it's a
weird concept
I'll get more wood Hey look at Enderman
I'm gonna stare at him he looks unhappy
he's up he's here now I'll guess you're
starting narrowing this out shouldn't we
yeah I know that doesn't look right do
you hear that I said it sounds evil
whatever it was I think that I think
this is all right Bob I found a mountain
where where the hell are you go why I
couldn't tell you if I wanted we get a
reckoner to you with you down the road
reconnoiter reconnoiter freakin Rican
our reconnoiter that's a word they're
gonna remember don't make fun of me
raaaarrh interrogator let's promote what
you said mark ah oh
oh wait I don't know what the problem is
with your setup but it's really funny
wait don't you play this like 12 hours a
day why is it normally but the past like
three days it's been like a way um I'm
gonna screw you over
yeah well Yami likes me getting screwed
over he's just like you mark yeah yeah
you're like with Lori uh-huh uh-huh
uh-huh
get it good we had sex huh who's getting
me more wood I have a bunch of wood why
do we have a floating boat here oh never
mind just decide to leave I'm getting
shadown the ghost boats are leaving us
the ghost boats are floating admittedly
you're getting stoned mark what's going
on over there man guess some good ass
[ __ ] man
dude hey yummy you play - did you play
containment breach right yeah yeah how
many episodes cuz I've milked that [ __ ]
for life basically I made two two
episodes and I recorded one last night I
got the most updated version and I uh
those this is like this new enemy and
it's like a creek or something on ya
grasshopper that's what it would you I
recorded 28 episodes of uh 20 a or 21
sorry
have you been killed by the grasshopper
yeah no I didn't know that it could kill
you can you see it yeah I thought out
the corner of my eye oh so it's just
banana man which is the alien which
kills Jimmy would banana man never mind
give it to Bob I'll give it to Lori her
guys saw Lori didn't uh-huh oh hey away
from her I might be able to log in long
enough to kill you
Mary so I'm gonna build an axe here you
can have mine no just give me the wood
no thank you no thank you sir
yeah why am i hang on and I see the
Enderman again I'm looking at him look
what's going on here
oh the aim do you know what right here
fob where I'm staying
okay got the Entenmann's here enter man
is here you guys
Entenmann's here spot this bowl looks
really bad are there so many guys the
Enderman I'm he's here now
guys where am i oh I hear it that's good
he sounds really creepy now
that's creepier than normal cream what
is up with that okay so this how this
boat is lovely and all but it's not
anywhere near any good resources that's
fine and that we can somehow sail it to
where we need to go I can't I destroy
this block oh I think we're in the spawn
Wade no I think our boat is permanently
but really Bilbao
oh you guys are Sadducees oh yeah haha
oh I'm just gonna play minesweeper I
forget this we should do that we should
find a cooperative minesweeper and have
a let's play minesweeper I have a
feeling ricochet Herschel somebody would
screw us whoever market why would I do
that
ah shame hey guys I found a six I'm
gonna click on all of them
ah you know my minesweeper humor doesn't
work out oh oh wait I just loaded up
single-player thought you're talking
about minecraft you're saying no I
didn't know I was talking about
minesweeper oh okay oh I found here he
is force above we need this spawn moved
what you guys Yami what I are found
another island well good we haven't even
explored this island oh I think I see a
house or something on it I don't know
whoa my rehearsal kids don't like house
but I'm going towards it unfortunately I
lost my boat I'm swimming Jarrett Bob Oh
God ha ha ha we're all drowning what yes
I see a house well why are you going
that way there's an island over here
wait we're closer one no no dosti oh
there's a
also over here though I'm with Yami I'm
going oh I see I see oh let's do it
mashed potatoes
oh yeah that's Yami's nickname mashed
potatoes mm-hmm does everybody love math
okay really fun big in the back and
watching everyone swim it like half a
mile purred like day what you need to
work on your exaggerations wait oh wow
why'd you hit me
speeding up you're swimming which is
actually it did work actually do it
again not we're gonna axe thank you oh
oh oh no I do it either you dick you
said all the nags you said nothing about
a sword here we hit you with my hoe no
I'm good I'm here already thank you very
much what is this don't hit me with
Laurie
oh let's see what you did there
oh I mean I can't deny it she did sleep
with you yeah what the hell is this I
know the Hydra huh that sounds not very
ominous on this whole Wade I found beds
check it out umm wait I think you
misunderstand how this whole works wait
wait where yes
whoa whoa whoa whoa I saw something Bob
go away Oh
huh whatever is out there made oh my god
what's down here it's creepy there's
something in here holy [ __ ] it's like a
chair facing a black abyss in one room
well I got kids whoa whoa whoa whoa hang
on oh I got a bunch of arrows Oh all the
arrows Oh what uh um also I got five
bows Oh hooked up what is this place is
this part of Lawson is this a lost thing
I don't know I don't feel like a steel
pole what the hell hi Bob oh yeah
there's a button on your side Bob press
it don't break it
jeez you're such a dick don't press it
rosette no don't press that I pressed it
nothing happens I am a mom's stupid why
you think nothing happens
hey the store oh there's the door button
hey you want me to do my moose man
impression not Billy I don't have a bear
can I cleaned up dammit I should leave
my room a mess good night yeah hey why's
our water here Wade oh no where's your
water here oh this is a drowning room oh
let me out - okay yeah yabai this dad's
pretty funny keep you away from your
[ __ ] Yami why why are you guys
always like so far away from me
we just wander around you gotta clean it
Yami down what it what have you been
doing
yummy huh coming out to get you are you
I wish there was more stuff in this
place digging Yami I was diggin I marry
my daughter come here Turner okay come
here come here come here
I know there's another building over
here you guys go in that one yeah yeah I
go hey good going here ha
come with me thank God we have you honey
follow me uh-uh never had this power
are going this room okay going on room
okay hey I'm not in that one there okay
okay oh wait no oh how do you hit me I
can't let you out if you kill me all
right okay sure come on come on
whoo Ruby come on that's trippy get out
wait come on get out Yami I'm between
the two why are you trotting our guests
oh no no any kicks because there's a new
version of Optifine available maybe oh
no y-you you be stupid wait and not do
goodness
I don't cast on a bunch of art galleries
for no reason okay good this much yeah
part of lost in some way or another I've
already watched season one I've never
watched any season ones good no I found
iron tools wait why are you guys again
we're all spread out now you're on your
own
I'm only um I barely called dibs on the
shittiest building here it's it's
supposed to rooms with art all over it
hey no go in there it's such music the
worst building ever what is with these
are these animal cages
Asha I have myself days no I didn't okay
this is secretly Human Centipede Ellen
hey it gave me a phase I found a plane
I found fish I found a plane we're a
workout is it working a working plane
yeah
Hey Hey so unlike some like this girl
hitch now like I can't get through the
walls here where a woman's I saw the
world Yami where since just um one set
well I found it oh look it's a plane
yeah oh maybe this is like the start
we're both like the beginning of lost
when you go on this plane then it
crashes uh uh uh
Oh Oh did you push that button I pressed
both of the buttons but nothing happened
I think we need for where's the plane
it's right you know over to the left
there I was I went to the left kinda
it's in the UM it's over you know where
is everything we have fuel really forest
hey a plane
why is there no passengers we are
through there the passengers they're
right here Oh
I'll see you I'm gonna kill right now I
must be crazy in my old age mysterious
forces that somehow come and the driver
actually look kind of intimidating with
the glasses and like the leather helmet
coming like right over top hmm oh great
and wondrous mysterious force that
controls the island of lost give us
purpose and meaning as we probably heard
there's control room with buttons I'm
pressing him yeah yeah we pressed him
already nothing I'm pretty sure they did
that a while ago yeah I got kick ah ha
ha ha
guys I've broken one of the wheels Bob
look out the window
there's something on the wing some thing
I'm flying a plane
no no just playing where his plane ain't
do nothing plain ain't even did enough
wasn't there a call of duty level what
about B God knows it College ah that was
good it was a Call of Duty level with
the plane wasn't it yeah we have to like
storm the play there were a couple that
involved there's a couple of involved I
don't know Kyle Dubes that's a couple
that involve planes Oh dirty sucks right
Yami but it's like I love Coolidge yeah
[ __ ] you then
I love call of duty 2 what do you play
on yon I play zombies me - you play on
PC what the hell is everyone's deal with
TF series
ah zombies I don't like that game mode I
like I think I don't understand what
everyone thinks it's the best thing
that's ever had to have an IRA a stone
axe to break diamond and get the block o
stone axe wait Walker much
games then commies Gaius I found
something I want
defeat that one of T and T when we're
over here on the right near the wing of
the plane oh yeah how about that that's
so strange that that's there I can't see
it anymore though huh oh look and
there's flit and still here no oh my god
it goes so far down oh my god Oh God
when you were like try to stop it you
should chop each other oh my god
that was just about the dumbest thing
I've done today okay Oh yamimash levels
this now do my craft gods hate me too Oh
hmm
found it to go what happened to the
bi-racial ah well I don't know what
happened but there was an explosion
that's all we know oh no damn it wait
what I do I'm in the hole now he's just
saying damn it Wade in general you know
like we usually do
okay Oh magical space gods that control
the universe
what are you Scientologists maybe
psychologist maybe I don't know it's a
legitimate religion me I'm there Shane
huh
Shane believes in Scientology l.ron
hubbard genius here to save us with our
a secondary explosion over here what's
this Oh what did i do I just like a
lobby all to his death right next you
did nothing
to stop it well that was our only escape
from the islands I couldn't because I
got kicked
Oh No why do you do that I didn't do
anything
you cut the ground out right from
underneath me damn yeah you did cuz I
fell down the hole right next to you me
yes didn't oh did I burn up I might have
I'm right here I'm because I fell down
that holy you just maybe I didn't but I
might have ha ha ha what Oh No hi he
didn't cuz he might have thought about
doing no look how effective that is what
[ __ ] ah dirty American Oh Bob look look
behind you look behind you Bob look on
the ground behind you Bob Bob look down
oh oh my oh my hey Mark what do you
still have that thing that you I died
yeah where'd you die I don't know but
just you're a good thing that I don't
have that anymore I would sure like a
flint so I can make a lighter for my car
you should go oh no oh there's t-80u
raining down I'm good
god mode enabled what I'm the best
No very before ah this is my honey
really hard to get kicked if I was going
oh this is by far my favorite Oh God
Wow it's still going still raining down
from the sky
grant done yeah a chopper extends not
done on my screen okay
mmm done here oh I got booted Oh No ah
zombie bold left the game
Oh Oh God how are we still here oh gods
have abandoned us no no all right I'm
trapped in this hole I might be god mode
by I don't think I can get out eyes
where am I we're on the Graber burger
garden where are you Yami I don't know I
I'm in the sea I feel like I prayed down
if you type slash up a key on me that
that still works
Oh ready yeah oh my god
hmm whoa this is a really deep crack hey
Wade great burger comes telling you
about the creeper oh I heard the M I
found a way out well oh where oh I see
who clever
it's dangerous cuz there's lava
underneath the water
oh god oh no oh why we got this
oh no the lavas coming in oh don't worry
about it we're fine no no I'm not fine
creepers coming down the waterfall why
God why oh the ocean spilling in oh oh
it's the ocean I got it no we're all so
deep that the ocean is spilling into it
yeah I'm gonna say this right now yeah
I'm gonna say
just right now yeah and guys hang on hey
well you're right now I got kicked cuz
flying is not enabled apparently why
don't you assume that that wasn't a pole
don't know it just said that I didn't
try anything and today there's so much
love at Berkeley under the creepers I
AMA stairs on that I'm gonna saw the
Apple I must say this right now okay
guys listening the other thing no guys
listening
wait Yami listen oh no I got ya okay
that was a pathetic explosion there is
nothing about that explosion no good at
all that was the worst
it is busiest hi anybody explosion I've
ever seen in my life just maybe take
that zombie buffin me oh wait what hey
if it didn't crash other servers that
are just adjacent to it oh okay get some
I spawned falling huh yeah that's the
new spawn is like way up in the air it's
concerning there's a strange all this
tnt suddenly started appearing all right
what have to be here oh my god shame
hahaha we should have like a TNT box
that we all get dropped in that would be
great hahaha
I like how Marcus king of the TNT oh
holy [ __ ]
Oh Oh God
I made it to the ocean I think I'm
actually gonna survive this one that
wasn't even that wasn't bad but the
ocean is kind of all in now this it's so
long you're spilling in it just is the
ocean oh god oh my favorite thing it
mashed potatoes leaves no yes
I don't know we oh he's really quiet oh
that's it yummy talk louder oh it is
ocean now haha oh god no I like the
three segments of tree trunks that are
hovering over the ocean lava under the
ocean over the eyes yeah yeah oh I'm
totally going to explore that [ __ ]
I love glitch ocean my favorite kind of
ocean Oh coolest thing ever
oh my god they caught me off I would
really like how it's dark down here it
would look like a nice touch
love to have a city that's built like
this like under just a layer of water
you would call it Atlantis it was that
original in my Accord we Quakers ticket
Lulu what did you make handle it wasn't
here did you just make that up Bob or is
that some something yeah okay good no I
just picked up it's really funny people
go you're sneaking lube and Lou okay
actually my my climbing so slow this uh
and we're out of time well surprisingly
were suddenly out of time we answer once
again we got nothing done hey we built a
yeah we didn't get it ah don't like that
more tentative oh what's ah it's like a
TNT penis sticking out of the ground
there that's a cavity sure yeah alright
so I made it out thank you everybody so
much for watching thank you yamimash for
being with us again
are no problem I'm in case no one knows
who you are you know really expensive to
fly over her from whatever Wade there
has a channel that Lord Lord minion 777
that's the nicest thing you've ever said
about me so uh yeah thank you everybody
so much for watching and as always we'll
see you in the next video bye bye
everybody